i need another the belt was respected by
her own kind to fight at our side
against inaudible that could make all
the difference she's not gonna trust you
and here i am
hey guys pete here this will be my short
preview video for the expanse season 6
episode 5. it's titled why we fight and
it pains me to say that it is the
penultimate episode of the final season
we are almost at the finish line i've
got an episode description and two short
teasers to discuss and i'll take a
closer look at last week's x-ray episode
that featured clarissa mal and was
titled nightwatch i'll be getting into
all of that right after this quick
spoiler warning if any of the stuff i
just mentioned sounded like spoilers to
you then this is your chance to leave
and with that out of the way let's get
into it
the x-ray bonus for episode 4 opens with
another reference to one ship it says
the doctrine of one ship arose from
paradoxes the cult of space and the heat
of the drive bright stars and pure
darkness companionship in the void
clarissa has the watch while everyone's
asleep and since the ship mostly flies
itself in this situation as holden told
her there isn't much to do she pulls up
the maintenance schedule and heads to
the reactor room before making her way
to the galley for some heavily salted
food her hand terminal chimes and she
gets a notification to find out from a
news feed that her father died in prison
it says the cause of death was an
underlying medical condition and when
they talk about his family they say that
his daughters julie and clarissa
pre-deceased him which means the
official story is that she died at the
pit when the rocks hit earth as she's
taking the news in she activates her
mods and crushes her hand terminal it
cuts to black there and when it comes
back she's on the floor in the aftermath
of her freakout she comes to and grabs
the nub that was her hand terminal which
is no longer very useful and then opens
her personal journal through the rossi's
voice system she says that the doctor in
the pit told her that the parent-child
relationship is primal and that it
doesn't have to make sense it's just
baked into the kind of primates we are
that you always care about your parents
clarissa didn't believe it but now she's
feeling the weight of this loss she
thinks why am i angry why am i angry now
you didn't die to hurt my feelings i was
never gonna see you again anyway why
does it even matter i wish you were a
better man i wish you were a better
father i wish you loved me i wish i
hadn't loved you i thought this was a
great solo scene for the clarissa
character nadine nicole did a fantastic
job and the character does get some
closure here which never happened in the
books the presumption was that jules
pierre mao would die in prison but as
she references here there was never any
contact or really any communication
between them and you had the idea that
he would have thought she was dead it
seems fitting to provide an end for this
character who was so important in the
first two seasons so another solid entry
in the one ship series clarissa
confronting her family issues i thought
the use of the internal cameras was a
nice touch it added to the feel of life
on a ship hurling through the vast
emptiness of the void and it was an
interesting take on how life continues
to go on even in times of war i'm
looking forward to the last two the
episode 5 description for why we fight
reads past converge on series when
drummer and her fleet arrive to aid the
relief effort holden tries to convince
ava sarala to release crucial
information that might avert catastrophe
but she has her own request of him as
amos and bobby get a little r r at the
station naomi has a difficult and
long-awaited reunion i guess it wasn't a
big jump to put together that drummer
might take her pirate booty over the
series to help the people out there that
certainly sounds like what this
description is saying and it also
confirms that holden and the rossi have
made it there as well it looks as though
everyone will be on series for the fifth
episode the two teasers this week are
sort of two halves of the setup for a
big meeting on series last week in the
x-ray photos section they accidentally
uploaded a scene from episode 5 the
scene that we see coming together in
these teasers i imagine a lot of people
noticed that when they were in there
watching the night watch episode the
teasers show us how that comes together
we see holden on what looks like the
xenobia and avasarala tells him that she
needs an ally a belter who is respected
by her own kind to fight at their side
against inaros that could make all the
difference and she's right drummer just
made a dramatic speech in the last
episode calling marco out she's
respected by belters for sure and
strategically this would be amazingly
helpful for the united fleet holden
brings up the big problem though drummer
has no love for the free navy she's
actively trying to undermine their power
but there's still a big difference in
going against them independently as a
belter for belters and fighting on the
side of the inners it's night and day as
far as what the reaction of her people
would be it's a very tricky situation
plus she doesn't have a good reason to
trust the un the mcrn or avasarala
personally there is a long history of
reasons why she wouldn't want to as
viewers we like the character avasarala
because she's fun to watch and she's
competent and she's really interesting
but to belter she is the face of the
oppressor she embodies generations worth
of exploitation and abuse we know that
the secretary general came a long way
from her earth must come first days when
she was hanging belters on hooks in the
first season but i think monica did a
pretty good job in the last episode of
pointing out that she's still a work in
progress and besides that like i said
she is the symbol of the inner planets
not many belters would be fans the
second teaser shows us that they will be
coming together for a public meeting
which just sort of drips with everything
you love about the expanse in one place
and i think the and here i am as an
introduction makes for a great opening
to the negotiations this is something to
look forward to early in the season i
was thinking it was kind of an odd
choice to have the acting secretary
general so close to the action there
just seems like there are a lot of
different ways things could go wrong
with that but if it were all in service
of these two meeting face to face in the
middle of series in front of a crowd
then i'm okay with it there's also some
action at the ring gate slipped in there
for good measure admiral carino had to
go ahead from mcrn command to make their
way out to the ring gate and cause
problems for the free navy you can't
really make out what's happening in the
bit they show here but she was confident
that their stealth ships would be able
to take out the century ships and we do
see something getting blown up that's
all there really is in the teasers i
don't see anything that connects to the
line in the description about holden
trying to get avasarala to release
something that might avert catastrophe
so i'll stay away from that and focus
instead on the idea of bobby and amos on
series station looking for r and r that
seems like a good place to leave things
i had to move the live stream back one
day this week so if you're watching this
video before 6 pm eastern time on
tuesday january the 4th make sure you
tune into that for a deep dive
discussion on episode 4. those give me a
chance to take a much closer look at the
interesting bits that i don't get around
to in the episode recaps they've been a
lot of fun it's also a chance to answer
some questions and get a conversation
going so come and check it out if you're
around let me know in the comments what
you thought about clarissa's mini
episode what you thought about these
teasers and what you're hoping to see in
episode 5. please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon